and let me say a little bit about the
format for this afternoon's discussion
before introducing the speakers so our
two speakers will each give a talk
they'll then be
break and then there'll be a discussion
following the break and our two speakers
let me introduce David Albert first but
let me say something about the the
format which is the the two speakers
have actually been working on issues
related to the physics and metaphysics
of time and it's clear from the
acknowledgments and their papers that
their work has evolved in discussion
with each other so it's really fabulous
to have them both presenting this
afternoon and have us a chance to
participate to the discussion between
them that are shaped their work so our
first speaker is David Albert who is the
Frederick Woodbridge professor of
philosophy at Columbia University his
work has been important on a variety of
topics and foundations of physics so in
particular and foundations of quantum
physics and more recently in foundations
of statistical mechanics his three books
have really shaped the field the first
quantum mechanics and experience was
published in 1992 a second focused on
foundations of statistical mechanics
time and chance and his most recent book
after physics has just appeared and so I
look forward to the discussions that
that book provokes and I look forward to
his talk which will be on mechanical
explanations in the direction of time
thank you Chris thank you for inviting
me it's very nice to be here
ok let me let me start off by saying
something about what I'm going to mean
for the purposes and in the context of
the conversation like the one we're
supposed to be having today when I say
things like mechanical or mechanical
explanation what I'm gonna mean here by
a mechanical feature of the world is
just anything of or about or related to
distributions of material bodies or mass
densities or physical fields over some
fundamental arena
as opposed to say features of the
structure of that arena itself which are
conceived of as somehow prior to an
independent of those distributions and
what I'm going to mean by mechanical
explanation of this or that feature of
the world is an explanation
in terms of distributions like that and
of the laws that govern them and I take
it that one of the reasons that Tim and
I have been invited to have a discussion
about these sorts of things here is that
the two of us have different intuitions
about what features of the world are
even in principle susceptible of the
kind of thing I've been calling a
mechanical explanation and which aren't
and and a particularly conspicuous case
in point and I take it this is why the
organizers chose this title concerns the
difference between the past and the
future but I'll get to that in a few
minutes I want to approach it by way of
something a little more general first so
consider for example the question of
geometry and let me confine myself just
for the moment just for the sake of
simplicity to a sort of pre relativistic
geometry of space as opposed to time
think to begin with of a world that
consists in its entirety of n classical
particles floating around in a
three-dimensional Euclidean space with
Cartesian coordinates XYZ under the
influence of a Hamiltonian and for those
of you who don't know what a Hamiltonian
is all you really need to know about it
is that this is a function from which we
can extract the complete laws of motion
of a set of particles like this this is
a function which contains all the
information we need in order to
formulate by a straightforward
algorithmic procedure the laws of motion
so it's a way of encoding those laws of
motion good think of a world that
consists in its entirety of M classical
particles floating around in a
three-dimensional Euclidean space with
Cartesian coordinates XYZ under the
influence of a Hamiltonian like this and
Jim this is these Hamiltonians contain
two terms this is called a kinetic
energy term this is called a potential
energy term I want to focus on the
potential energy term imagine that the
functions vkj the potential energy
functions are structured in such a way
as to accommodate the existence of
things like tables and chairs and clocks
and measuring rods and information
processing systems and so on of course
this is almost certainly impossible
that's why classical mechanics is no
good that's why we need theories of
fields and quantum theories and so on
and so forth but temporarily imagining
otherwise isn't going to do any harm I
think insofar as our purposes here are
concerned and if we imagine that the
reason I want to imagine that is that
it'll put us in a position to ask
questions about how a world like this
would appear to its inhabitants and by
appearances here I don't mean mental
phenomena but I just mean the outcomes
of ordinary experiments using
measuring-rods and clocks and and so on
and so forth okay so the specifically
geometrical appearances of a world like
this are obviously going to be Euclidian
and three-dimensional but why exactly
this is presumably going to have
something to do with the mathematical
form of the potential energy term in
this Hamiltonian H the fact in
particular that this potential energy
term here is a function of the
three-dimensional distance that is
people can recognize this familiar
Pythagorean term here the difference the
square of the difference in the
x-coordinates opposed to square the
difference in the y-coordinates plus the
square of the difference in the z
coordinates the fact that this vkj is a
function of the distance between
particle K and particle J in the
background three-dimensional Euclidean
space means that the interactions
between those particles can be thought
of as recording that distance as making
it man
just as making it visible in the way
those particles move around the fact
that the vkj are functions of the
distances between pairs of particles is
what makes it possible for example for
there to be collections of such
particles whose stable configurations
have a characteristic length in the
background three-dimensional Euclidean
space and can therefore be put to work
as things like measuring rods good but
what if the relationship between the
geometry of the background space and the
mathematical form of the Hamiltonian is
more complicated than that
consider for example a world that
consists of n classical particles
floating around not in a Euclidean
3-dimensional background space but in
some arbitrarily curved 3-dimensional
space atom a swith the topology of our
three say but not with a flat geometry
and suppose that suppose that we equip
this curved background space with some
set of generalized coordinates called XY
and Z again and suppose that those
particles happen to float around in that
space under the influence of a
Hamiltonian which depends on these
generalized coordinates XYZ in exactly
the way that the earlier one this one
here depended on the Cartesian
coordinates XYZ note that this
superficial similarity the fact that
they have the same dependence on XYZ
masks very profound differences in this
world unlike in the previous one this
expression down here is emphatically not
the spatial distance between particles J
and K in this three-dimensional
background curved space indeed in worlds
like this there's in general going to be
no simple and uniform expression for the
distance between two particles in terms
of their generalized coordinates and
Hamiltonians like this one
are not going to accommodate the
existence of collections of particles
that have stable configurations that
excuse me it is not going to accommodate
the existence of particles that have
stable configurations that have any
characteristic length in the background
curved space but note as well that a
Hamiltonian like this could support the
existence of collections of particles
that do have stable configurations of
particular characteristic Delta x
squared plus Delta y squared plus Delta
Z squared values and more generally the
fact that vkj is a function of these
three differences means that
interactions between those particles can
be seen as recording that quantity as
making it manifest as making it visible
in the motions of those particles and so
the three-dimensional space of the world
we're considering now notwithstanding
the fact that in actuality it's curved
is apparently or at least I don't see
how to avoid the conclusion that it's
going to appear to its inhabitants
however detailed and precise an
extensive there empirical investigations
to be flat that is it's going to look to
them exactly like the previous actually
flat space looked and we might be even
begin to wonder in circumstances like
these about exactly what it's supposed
to mean to say that the space in
question here is actually curved because
the actual geometry of the background
now appears to play no role whatever in
the production of these geometrical
appearances
it's the dynamics that seems to do all
the work a Hamiltonian like this one is
going to produce flat Euclidean
three-dimensional appearances in a way
that's entirely independent of what the
actual geometry of the background three
dimensional manifold may happen to be
and as a matter of fact it's apparently
going to produce those appearances in a
way that's entirely independent of
whether or not that background manifold
has any intrinsic geometry
at all this second example people may
recognize is a sort of inverted and
slightly better dressed variant of punk
arrays old parable of the finite
two-dimensional Euclidean Discworld the
one that contrives by means of the
effects of spatial variations in the
temperature on the lengths of
measuring-rods to appear to its
inhabitants as an infinite Lobachevsky
and plain that parable of course led to
a famous debate between conventionalist
and verification ax stand scientific
realist accounts of the epistemology of
geometry but the lesson i want to draw
from it here is something at right
angles to all that something in
particular about physics what the second
example suggests to me is that the
fundamental arena in which the world is
rightly pictured is unfolding isn't the
geometrical space but nearly a
differentiable manifold something that
is with no a fine or metrical structure
at all the geometrical properties of the
world are rather emergent things things
that have to do not with the structure
of the arena itself but like tables and
chairs and universities with the action
of the dynamics with the distribution of
the matter and fields that is over the
fundamental arena we can think of a set
of points that make up the fundamental
arena as something like the totality of
opportunities for things at any
particular time to be one way or another
or you could put it this way what we
have in mind what we mean to say when we
refer to some set of points as the
fundamental arena of the world is that a
specification of what's physically going
on at each one of those points at any
particular time amounts to a complete
specification of the physical situation
of the world at that time and one of the
things that we learn from science one of
the things that we learn in particular
from the fact that the fundamental
dynamical laws take the form of
differential equations is that that
totality although it's something
considerably less than a gym
Trickle space is also something
considerably more than a mere collection
of points
it must apparently have the structure of
a differentiable manifold the conception
of the fundamental space of the world
that all of us grew up with them seems
to include both the idea of a
fundamental arena and the idea of a
fundamental geometry but what we've
learned here suggests that these two
ideas are worth prying apart from one
another the fundamental arena of the
world doesn't need to be thought of as
having any geometry and what geometry
the world does have turns out not to be
any part of its fundamental structure
but rather a byproduct of its dynamical
laws and so if all this turns out to
generalize in the appropriate way to
relativistic and quantum mechanical
theories and so on and so forth
the geometrical structure of the world
counts as what I was referring to above
as a mechanical phenomenon of nature
there's lots more to say about this in
connection with all sorts of different
questions let me just briefly mention
one here because it's one that Tim and I
have talked about for years with each
other in the example we considered above
the topology of the emergent geometry
turns out to be the same as the topology
of the fundamental arena both of them in
particular turn out to have the topology
of r3 but on the sort of picture I've
been sketching out here there's going to
be nothing necessary or general or even
particularly natural about that in an
n-dimensional excuse me in an end
particle nonrelativistic quantum
mechanical world for example what I'm
calling the fundamental arena that is
the totality of opportunities for the
universal wavefunction at any particular
time to have one value or another forms
a manifold with with the topology of our
three end rather than our three but the
mathematical form of the Hamiltonian of
a world like this will dictate
nevertheless that the emergent geometry
is going to be Euclidian and
three-dimensional and I suspect that
many of the differences
between quantum-mechanical and classical
kinds of physics can be traced back to
this distinctive topological coming
apart in the quantum mechanical case but
not in the classical one of the
fundamental arena and the emergent
geometrical space but that's all i want
to say about that here if I tried to go
further it would carry us much too far
afield let me turn to what I was
supposed to be talking about which is
the question of time there's an ancient
and powerful temptation a temptation to
which Tim succumbs to suppose that there
must be something metaphysically
fundamental something somehow deeper
them or prior to the distribution of the
local properties themselves to the
foliation of the world in two times but
I think that temptation is at least
worth trying to resist and the modern
scientific history of that resistance
the thought that is well there are a lot
of sources of this but here's one
particularly vivid one the thought that
the very distinction between time and
space itself is the thought is the sort
of thing that I referred to above as a
mechanical phenomenon of nature goes
back at least as far as the famous 1951
paper by DC Williams called the myth of
passage in which Williams confesses
himself and now I'm quoting more than
half convinced by the oddly repellent
hypothesis that the peculiarity of the
time dimension is thus not primitive but
wholly a result of those differences in
the mere de-facto run and order of the
worlds filling here's the idea consider
a manifold call this one the ER
arena as opposed to the fundamental
arena we were talking about before with
the topology of RM for some number M and
some coordinate ization x1 through XM
over which local properties the presence
of the absence or the absence of
particles say or the valve
use of fields or what have you are
distributed it may happen that this
distribution has the special
mathematical feature that there is some
relatively simple set of rules which
relate the various sub distributions of
those properties over the various M
minus 1 dimensional sub manifolds that
is it may be possible it may be the case
that this distribution is such that
there's a certain way of cutting this
arena up into into parallel non
intersecting slices such that there are
fairly simple rules connecting the
distribution of particles and fields
over one of those slices to the
distribution of particles and fields
over others of those slices suppose for
example that the dimensionality of this
manifold happens to be equal to 4 and we
call our coordinates W XY and Z and that
the distribution of properties over this
four dimensional arena happens to obey a
rule to the effect that for every value
of alpha the three dimensional sub
manifold W equals alpha contains exactly
n points which are occupied by particles
and that each one of those points is
invariably occupied by a different kind
of particle with different internal
properties and that the coordinates of
those occupied points vary with the
value of alpha in accord with
differential equations that you get from
a Hamiltonian like this where X I is the
x coordinate of the point occupied by
the I kind of particle and so on and so
forth rules like that then if there are
such are called dynamical laws and the
very sub manifolds W equals alpha that
those rules linked together are called
temporal instants and the coordinate W
the one that indexes those sub manifolds
is called time and it should be clear
that the business of talking about one
or another of the
coordinates X Y Z W as the real or the
actual or the underlying time coordinate
in a way that somehow supposed to be
prior to an independent of the
distributions of matter and fields over
the arena it's gonna be exactly as empty
as here as the business of talking about
the real or the actual or the underlying
geometry of space turned out to be in
the examples we were discussing earlier
consider for example another
distribution of properties over the same
four-dimensional arena a distribution
which is mathematically obtained from
the one we were discussing before by
means of what you might loosely refer to
as a ninety degree clockwise rotation in
the W X plane in the context of a
distribution like that it would be X and
not W that plays the role of time and we
could even imagine two such
distributions the first of which is a
distribution of particles and the second
of which is a distribution of Q
particles which are related to one
another by precisely the sort of 90
degree clockwise rotation in the W X
plane that I mentioned a minute ago and
which are superimposed on one another
that is what you are superimposed on one
in the same background fundamental
four-dimensional arena in that case I
take it the right thing to say would be
that the ER arena is inhabited
simultaneously in scare quotes by two
causally autonomous worlds one of which
consists of particles and the other with
Q particles the particles and the Q
particles evolve completely
independently of one another and
moreover W is the time parameter in the
particle world and X is the time
parameter in the Q particle world there
is of course a great deal more to the
phenomenon of temporality than a mere
foliation of the ER arena into times
there are and particularly in particular
worlds like ours excuse me there are in
particular in worlds like ours all sorts
of incredibly important distinctions
thermodynamic distinctions distinctions
of epistemic access distinctions of
cause of
so on and so forth between the past and
the future and there is the sense of
passage and there is the directedness of
agency and there is the singularity of
the now and what have you and the
business of understanding the foliation
of the world in two times in terms of
the distribution of local fundamental
properties is only the first and most
elementary step in a much larger project
aimed at understanding the phenomenon of
temporality as a whole in terms like
that and I want to spend the time that I
have left how much time do I have left
okay good I want to spend the time that
I have left talking just a little bit
about how that project might be pursued
let me start off by reminding you of the
basic logical structure of classical
statistical mechanics statistical
mechanics begins with a postulate to the
effect that a certain very
natural-looking measure on the set of
possible exact micro conditions of any
classical mechanical system is to be
treated or is to be understood as a
probability distribution over those
micro conditions the measure in question
here is as a matter of fact the simplest
imaginable measure on the set of
possible exact micro conditions of
whatever system it is one happens to be
dealing with the standard lebesgue
measure on the phase space of the
possible exact positions and momenta of
the Newtonian particles that make the
system up excuse me
and the thrust of all of the beautiful
and ingenious arguments of Boltzmann and
Gibbs and of their various followers and
collaborators was to make it plausible
that for any true thermo dynamical law
to the effect that macro condition a
evolves over such-and-such an interval
under such-and-such external
circumstances into macro condition B
then the overwhelming majority of the
volume of the region of face space
associated with macro condition a on the
above standard measure is taken up by
micro conditions which are sitting on
deterministic Newtonian trajectories
which pass under the allotted
circumstances at the end of the allotted
interval through the region of the phase
space associated with the macro
condition B and if these arguments
succeed and if they can be extended to
more up-to-date versions of the
fundamental dynamics and ontology of the
world then the above-mentioned
probability distribution over micro
conditions turns out to underwrite
enormous swaths of our everyday
empirical experience of the world but
there's a famous trouble with all this
and this is just the thermo dynamical
version of the more general problem of
the direction of time which is that all
of the above-mentioned arguments work
just as well in Reverse that all of the
above-mentioned arguments entail not
only that a half-melted block of ice
sitting at present in a warm room will
be more melted ten minutes from now than
it is at present but also and this is
the bad news that it was more melted ten
minutes ago than it is now
and it seems fair to say that we're as
sure as we are of anything that this
latter claim is not right and the
canonical method of patching this
trouble up the canonical approach that
is to the thermo dynamical problem of
the direction of time is to supplement
the dynamical equations of
and the statistical postulate with a new
and explicitly non time reversal
symmetric fundamental law of nature a
so-called past hypothesis to the effect
that the universe had some particular
simple compact symmetric cosmologically
sensible very low entropy initial macro
condition the patched-up picture then
consists of the complete deterministic
micro dynamical laws and a postulate to
the effect that the distribution of
probabilities over all of the possible
exact initial micro conditions of the
world is uniform with respect to the
lebesgue measure over all those possible
micro conditions of the universe which
are compatible with the initial macro
condition specified in this past
hypothesis and that the probabilities
are zero outside of that and with that
amended picture in place the arguments
of Boltzmann and Gibbs are going to make
it plausible
not only that paper will be yellower and
ice cubes more melted and people more
aged and smoke more dispersed toward the
future but that they were all less so
just as our experience tells us in the
past with that additional stipulation in
place put it another way the arguments
of Boltzmann and Gibbs are going to make
it plausible that the second law of
thermodynamics remains in force all the
way from the end of the world back to
its beginning what we have from
Boltzmann and Gibbs then is a
probability distribution over possible
initial micro conditions of the world
which when combined with the exact
deterministic microscopic equations of
motion apparently makes good empirical
predictions about the values of the
thermodynamic parameters of macroscopic
systems and it turns out and this is the
punchline I guess that there are reasons
to hope that this same simple
probability distribution over
microscopic initial conditions of the
universe can also offer us clear and
complete and perspicuous explanation
not only of the time asymmetry of
thermodynamics but of the time asymmetry
of our epistemic
access to the past and future and of the
time asymmetry of intervention that is
of the fact or of the conviction that by
acting now we can affect the future but
not the past and of the sense of passing
and of the uniqueness of the present and
in short of the whole phenomenon the
whole rich phenomenon of temporality the
business of explicitly putting these
explanations together is as I said a
large undertaking that encompasses the
work now of a growing number of
different investigators and it's still
very much underway and I'm not going to
be able to give you anything along the
lines of an exhaustive or systematic
description of that project here but I
want to point to one or two simple
fundamental observations that I hope
will suggest something about how such
explanations might ultimately look
consider to begin with the following two
different procedures for making
intertemporal inferences so procedure 1
start with some collection of facts f
about the physical condition of the
world at time t put a probability
distribution which is uniform with
respect to the standard measure on phase
space over all of the possible micro
conditions of the world which are
compatible with this set of facts f that
you happen to know evolve that
distribution forwards or backwards in
time by means of the microscopic
equations of motion so as to obtain
information about the physical condition
of the world
at other times call this inference by
prediction if the other time in question
is in the future of T and call it
inference by retro diction if the other
time in question is at them in the past
of T ok
the entirety of what we justifiably
believe about the future I suspect can
in principle be obtained by prediction
from the entirety of what we justifiably
believe about the present by Rhett but
repre dick ting from what we believe
about the present is a notoriously
terrible way of drawing conclusions
about the past one of the lessons of the
work of Boltzmann and Gibbs for example
is that retro dick ting from what we
know of the present is going to imply
that the half-melted ice in the glass of
water in front of me if there were one
was more melted ten minutes ago than it
is now and that I have never looked
younger than I do now which would be
horrible and that Napoleon never existed
and so on to second method of making
intertemporal inferences start with two
collections of facts about the physical
condition of the world f 1 and f 2 where
all the facts in f1 pertained to some
particular time t1 and all the facts in
f2 pertain to some other particular time
T to put a probability distribution
which is uniform with respect to the
standard measure on phase space over all
of the possible microscopic histories of
the world which are compatible with F 1
and F 2 and the microscopic equations of
motion and use that distribution to
obtain information about the physical
condition of the world at times between
T 1 and T 2 call this so the earlier one
was called inference by prediction or
retro diction call this inference by
measurement inference by measurement is
so called because it's modeled on the
logic of measuring instruments measuring
instruments that is are the sorts of
systems which reliably undergo some
particular transition when they interact
in the appropriate way with the system
they're designed to measure only in the
event that the measured system is at the
time of the interaction in one or
another of some particular collection of
physical situations
the record which emerges from a
measuring process is a relation if you
consider it properly between the
conditions of the measuring device at
the two opposite temporal ends of the
interaction the record bearing
conditions of measuring devices which
obtain at one temporal end of such an
interaction are reliable indicators of
the situation of the measured system at
the time of the interaction only in the
event that the measuring devices in it's
ready condition the condition that is in
which the device is calibrated and
plugged in and facing in the right
direction and in every other respect all
set to do its job at the interactions
other temporal end the sort of inference
from one makes from a recording is not
from one time to a second time in its
future or past as is the case in
prediction retro diction but rather from
2 times to a third one that typically
lies in between them and note and this
is the important point to note that
inferences by measurement can be
fantastically more powerful that
inferences by measurement can be
fantastically more informative than
inferences of the predictive ret redic
today think for an example for example
of an isolated collection of billiard
balls moving around on a frictionless
table and consider the question of
whether or not over the next 10 seconds
billiard ball number 5 is going to
collide with any of the other billiard
balls the business of answering that
question by means of prediction is
plainly going to require a great deal of
calculation and that calculation is
going to require as input a great deal
of information about the present it will
require in particular a complete
catalogue of the present positions and
velocities of every single one of the
billiard balls on the table but notice
that if we happen to know by hook or by
crook that billiard ball number 5 was
moving 10 seconds ago then the question
of whether or not billiard ball number 5
happens to have collided with any of the
other billiard balls over the past 10
seconds can be settled definitively in
the affirmative
without any calculation at all merely by
the single binary bit of information the
billiard ball number five is currently
at rest and note that where is the
information the billiard ball number
five was moving 10 seconds ago
and that it is now at rest is going to
suffice
excuse me and note that that I'm sorry
that whereas the information that ball
number five was moving ten seconds ago
and that it is now at rest is going to
suffice completely irrespective of how
many balls there are on the table to
settle the question of whether or not
billiard ball number five was involved
in a collision over the past 10 minutes
the amount of information we're going to
require in order to do them in order to
determine by means of prediction whether
or not billiard ball number five will be
in a collision over the next 10 seconds
is gonna rise and rise without any limit
as the number of balls on the table does
but there's an obvious puzzle about how
it is that inferences by measurement as
I'm calling them can ever actually
manage to get off the ground the game
here after all is to look at the
business of making inferences from one
time to another the game more
particularly is to look into what we can
know about the complete history of the
world from the vantage point of the
present and in the context of an
investigation like that the facts that
it's going to be appropriate to think of
as unproblematically given to us the
facts from which it's going to be
appropriate to think of these inferences
as starting out are presumably going to
be limited to facts about how the world
is now consider for example the case of
the billiard balls if I happen to know
that billiard ball number five was
moving 10 seconds ago then indeed I need
no no more of the present state of the
entire collection of balls than the
billiard ball number five is currently
at rest in order to conclude that
billiard ball number five has been
involved in a collision over the past
ten seconds but how is it that I ever do
have
to know that billiard ball number 5 was
moving 10 seconds ago
well presumably by measurement
presumably that is because I have a
record of it but how is it that I know
that the purported record in question is
actually reliable how is it that is that
I know that the measuring device which
was presently which presently bears the
purported record of billiard ball number
Five's having been in motion 10 seconds
ago was in fact in its ready condition
at the appropriate time prior to 10
seconds ago well presumably by means of
another measurement and before you know
it a ruinous world devouring regression
is underway which can only be stopped by
means of something we can be in a
position to assume about some other time
something of which we have no record
something which cannot be inferred from
the present by means of prediction or
retro diction something which is
sufficiently relentless investigation of
the ultimate grounds of our knowledge of
almost anything we know about the past
that the half-melted ice cube in front
of me was less melted 10 minutes ago
than it is now that I once looked
younger that Napoleon existed etc must
eventually lead back the ultimate
primordial mother as it were of already
conditions and the thought is that
there's an obvious candidate for just
such a primordial mother sitting right
in the centre of the standard
statistical mechanical account of the
second law of thermodynamics in the form
of this past hypothesis that I mentioned
earlier the thought is that it's because
the fundamental laws of physics contain
a past hypothesis but no analogous
future one that facts about the present
can be so mind bogglingly more
informative about what's already
happened than they ever are about what's
to come the thought is that there can be
measurements of the past but not the
future precisely because there is
something in the past but nothing
analogous in the future to put an end to
the regress I was talking about before
and it turns out do I have a few more
minutes
you'll take a few moments it turns out
that the flipside of all this has a
lesson in it about the asymmetry of
intervention think again of the
collection of billiard balls and suppose
and this is what's going to stand in in
the context of this very simple toy
example for a past hypothesis suppose
the ball number five was moving ten
seconds ago what we learned about that
sort of a collection of balls a few
minutes ago was that whether or not ball
number five will be involved in a
collision over the next ten seconds
depends on more or less everything about
the present condition of every single
one of the balls on the table but
whether or not ball number five has been
involved in a collision over the past 10
seconds can at least in some cases be
settled by the present condition of ball
number five all by itself and so very
crudely almost everything about the
physical condition of the world at
present can affect whether or not ball
number five will be involved in a
collision over the next 10 seconds but
almost nothing about the physical
condition of the world at present
nothing in this particular case saved
the present state of motion of ball
number five itself can affect whether or
not ball number five was involved in a
collision over the past 10 seconds and
so there are as it were a far wider
variety of potentially available routes
to influence over the future of the ball
in question here there are far wider
variety of what you might call causal
handles on the future of the ball in
question here then there are on its past
and all of this is going to generalize
what I say here is fairly
straightforwardly but that's not true
but it's going to generalize if all goes
well let's say two cases of worlds which
are much richer and much more
complicated and much more like our own
I'll leave it there thank you